Oh do ya.
Just when you thought the problem was solved because you haven't heard about it
for a while.
Everything's back to murderous cows and terror.
What happened in 2003 the US invaded Iraq because of its alleged connections to
terrorism and weapons of mass destruction at the time Sadam Hussein,
a brutal dictator world,
the country he was part of the Sunni minority and suppress the sheer majority.
Iraq was conquered fairly quickly,
but the U S had no plan for the country.
The until then suppressed Shia majority took over and began a pressing the sun
is because suppressing other phases proven to be such a good idea.
Unsurprisingly,
a Sunni rebel uprising began and terrorist groups like al Qaeda trickled into
Iraq and local forces.
Often former sunny military began fighting the US troops and the newly formed
Iraqi state peaking in a bloody civil war in 2006 since then,
people in Iraq have basically been segregated by religion.
So in a tragic irony of history,
the US invasion lets the formation of the very terrorists that u s wanted to
eliminate in the first place because Iraq was now the perfect training ground
for terrorism.
To understand this complicated conflict better,
we need to understand the relationship between the two main branches of the
Muslim faith,
Shia and Sunni Islam,
Sunni as make up about 80% of the Muslim world and Shia about 20% and the
hardliners on both sides don't like each other very much.
Saudi Arabia and Iran,
other two most powerful players in the game of faiths,
they both have no separation of state and religion,
domestic problems,
and a lot of oil money and they support groups that fight the other religious
orientation.
And what are those terror organizations supported by?
Saudi Arabia was the Islamic state in Iraq or Isi for short.
In 2010 the Arab spring happened and changed the whole situation in the Middle
East in Syria,
dictator Bashar Al Assad.
It didn't think much of resigning and started a gruesome civil war against his
own people.
The longer the war went on,
the more foreign groups joined the fight,
most of them for religious reasons and with the goal of building an Islamic
state and the region,
and one of them was the infamous Isi,
which now became the Islamic state in Iraq and Syria or isis.
They had fought in Iraq for years and had thousands of well trained and phonetic
soldiers.
They already choirs.
I controlled parts of northern Iraq and were very determined to build their
religious state and they changed the game in Syria like no one expected.
Isis was so unbelievably violent and radical that sooner was at war with almost
every other faction of the Syrian rebel armies.
They attacked and killed members of other Muslim terrorist groups in the
territories they controlled.
They built an Islamic state with rules are so strict that even the hardliners of
al Qaeda and Saudi Arabia was shocked and withdrew their support.
Isis has been accused of responsibility for multiple massacres against
civilians,
countless suicide bombings,
the hostage taking of women and children,
the execution of their prisoners and beheadings,
all kinds of medieval horrors.
We would rather not have to.
At a straight and this lovely gathering of human beings.
We,
he decided it was time to take more territory in Iraq.
Since the U s left Iraq,
the sheer prime minister and very al Maliki has monopolized power and
discriminated against sooners wherever possible.
The government of Iraq is widely regarded as being corrupt and capable,
and it's certainly hated by a large part of its citizens.
The Iraqi army consisting of about 300,000 soldiers was created using 25 billion
US dollars in tax money,
but it's not all to its government and has been withdrawing or completely
disbanded giving up city after city because Isis has announced that everyone who
opposes them will be killed.
They have proven they mean business.
By June,
2014 they'd conquered a big chunk of Iraq,
including Mosul,
Iraq,
second largest city.
They'd stolen hundreds of millions from captured banks making them the richest
terror organization on earth,
and they are constantly working on establishing a super medieval religious
state,
Iran and the u s or even considering working together as a fight them.
That's how gruesome the situation is,
events and a rock show.
Again,
that explosion that people you've defeated in a walk denying them power or
living in a stake in the rebuilding of the country is just sowing the seeds of
the next bout of violence.
Somehow we have to break this circle.